I think it's one over the years
there has been a great rivalry between the
US and Mexico and I think it's going to be a
great event there I think the heart
is divided because I'm Mexican but
this country also gives us a great
opportunity to be  Well, here may the best man win. It
's a beautiful new stadium
with state-of-the-art technology and our
national team is going to be there playing
a final. So I'm very
excited. The city is
excited. Many Mexicans are going to come
from Mexico and those who live here.  in the
usa
so it's going to be a great day for
mexico pegasys back and it's a
reality Hispanics in general not only
Mexicans are very excited about this
match
they have called me Cubans Salvadorans
Hondurans who are going to the game are going to
be supporting  mexico and well the
tourists will also
vigorously support the local economy so the
new stadium will attract a lot of
sports and shows from mexico and it
is very good because  e reflects the
composition of las vegas las vegas
is becoming more and more hispanic it's
a very big event that's in las
vegas' that has never seen a
gold cup final between the usa and mexico who
are rivals for many years
in the  football
may the best win but I'm mexico